PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Get Cooking in Cloud
where we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I am Priyanka Vergadia.
And in this episode-- ha--
[SIGHS]
Oh, my god.
That was some
serious earthquake.
Gosh, disasters like
this can be pretty
hard to deal with when you
have a huge online presence.
So let's see the recipe to
plan for a disaster like that.
When things like this,
this, or this happen,
you need to make sure the impact
on your business is minimal.
And for that, you need a
robust disaster recovery plan.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A disaster typically means a
service-interrupting event.
So what is disaster
recovery or DR?
Well, it's the amount
of impact a business
can take during a disaster.
We use two key metrics
to define the impact.
RTO, or recovery
time objective, which
is the maximum amount
of time your application
can be offline.
This usually depends on SLAs
you offer to your customers.
An SLA is a promise
made by you as a service
provider to your customers
about the availability
of your service and
the ramifications
of failing to deliver the
agreed-upon level of service.
RPO, or recovery
point objective,
is the maximum amount of time
during which the data might
be lost during an interruption.
Typically, smaller
RTO and RPO values
mean that the application
must recover quickly
from an interruption.
How quickly a system can recover
after a disaster is defined
by high availability and
disaster recovery patterns,
also known as HA
and DR patterns.
Let's consider this scenario.
I'm making some cakes and
cookies for a party, which
requires a mixer.
I'm on my first
batch of cookies.
And the mixer starts to
make some weird noises.
The manual says that the mixer
will fail with such a noise.
So I need to do
something to carry on
with the party preparations.
Hmm.
What do I do now?
I can call the mixer
company to come
fix it, which is obviously
going to take time
and won't really work best
given the party is today.
Or maybe I can try
to fix it myself
based on the instructions
in the manual.
Well, this will mean a small
pause in my preparation
but hmm, will bring
me back on track
a little bit quicker than
waiting for the mixer repair
guy.
Ha, what else can I do?
Well, I could also keep
going at a slow-mix option
where I can't really hear that
warning noise, in which case, I
have to slow down.
But the mixer's still working
so I can continue on and get
it fixed later.
This option would
definitely have less impact
on my party preparations,
at least, for today.
So let's review our options
in the DR terminology now.
If we call the mixer
company for a fix,
we have to stop making the cake
till they turn up and fix it.
It will be slow
and time consuming.
But eventually, we'll
be back working.
So this scenario is
closest to what we
could call a cold DR pattern.
If we try and fix
it ourselves, it's
a bit faster than
the cold pattern.
But since we still need
to pause making our cake
in order to fix the situation,
it is still slower than normal.
So this scenario is
closest to what we
would call a warm DR pattern.
And the option where we
continue working at slow speed
and decide to fix later
is the most efficient,
as I'm still making cakes
without stopping or pausing
and is closest to what we
would call a hot DR pattern.
Well, moral of
the story, we pick
a DR pattern that makes sense
for the business at hand.
In this case, it was
really serious business
of hosting a party.
And look how amazing
this cake turned out.
If you use Google
Cloud for DR, it
can greatly reduce
the costs that
are associated with achieving
both RTO and RPO values as
compared to fulfilling those
requirements on-premise.
For example,
traditional DR planning
requires you to account for
a number of requirements,
including capacity, security,
network infrastructure,
support, and bandwidth.
Google Cloud has
several features
that help bypass most of
these complicated factors
and reduces the cost of
managing a DR solution.
Global network, redundancy,
scalability, security,
and compliance are
a few such factors.
Keep following the
series for more on this.
Now let's see what
are some of the best
practices for planning
a DR strategy that
can apply to our business.
First and foremost, we want
to define our RTO and RPO
values because they would
indicate an appropriate DR
pattern.
Then we make sure that we have
a full end-to-end recovery plan.
Just backing up and archiving
data won't be enough.
Make our tasks as
specific as possible
so when the time comes
to execute the plan,
it does not just say,
run the restore script.
Well, from where?
What's the command?
Such information should be
there in the instructions.
Implement control measures.
Monitor and send alerts
when something destructive
happens, like spikes in
traffic or deletion in data.
Prepare the software,
verify that you
can install the
software from the source
or from a pre-configured image.
Make sure you have the
appropriate licenses
for that deployment.
Our continuous
deployment toolset
is an integral part of our
application deployment.
Make sure it's available
at the time of disaster
to recover the environment.
We should not forget about
security and compliance.
Configure security the same for
DR and production environments.
And last but most
important step,
make sure your DR plan works.
Maintain multiple paths for data
recovery and test it regularly.
That's all for today on
Get Cooking in Cloud.
Whether you are struck by
lightning or an earthquake,
hopefully you learned
some tips to recover.
Join us next time because
we will share the recipe
to implement DR in Cloud
for your applications
hosted on-premise.
If you would like to
see more such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]